[Applause]
kerry looking for that opening steps
back
crossover fires away wow
[Applause]
36 in the second half
another turnover curry on the run
and behind his back the magician
putting on a display here in the third
quarter steph curry's got 37.
he just keeps doing a game in game out
and he beat the clock from midcourt
[Music]
he banked it home we are watching
a player who is otherworldly
[Applause]
[Music]
unlimited range
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
62 62
and he actually surpasses his buddy clay
thompson knows where he is
[Applause]
steps back crossover fires away
curry extreme confidence here's the
chatter
deli's the curry stopper not on my watch
new york back up by 4.
[Applause]
and you know he's a basketball fan put
it behind his back gets a little help
from his teammate
and in the face of size drains another
three
rebound taken by iguodala they do have a
timeout
decide not to use it curry way downtown
bang
bang oh what a shot from curry
with six tenths of a second remaining
what up it's your boy adam lefko did you
like that content i know you like that
content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report